what Alvis all get the three parter
under pressure you'll take it though
cover the other night tiny she's from
[Applause]
just like that Westbrook dad a couple
weeks ago he didn't give sit up here to
fall over the top was replies one person
and transition go right back here back
to watch on Thunder live that's a good
fit the 24-second clock so that's what
you want to do you know you don't want
to follow the end of the shot clock
let's transition and it lists the easy
transition buckets cuz that should be a
transition bucket for the Thunder 5
Westbrook measuring he's got a cutter
Roberson
the final two minutes
[Applause]
lots of guns he had already in the
cookie jar
he's already beat right now he just
doesn't know it anytime you want a
shooter that mark the distance and your
arm is straight out like that you are
taught as a score all the way down let's
get a layup let's go for this six two
shifts to the corner
it was Jeremy grant and let me see if I
can do that one up I'll let you be the
each other that folks make a plate
[Applause]
[Music]
Westbrook passes six turnovers almost
even that's why he should accept it out
of Dada feisty Pitt out of staying
vertical Westbrook Patty Mills reached
in watch this right here patty don't
reach in
[Music]
[Applause]
two defenders live in the back door wide
open for our sake don't you treat
buckets the drop this is good right now
you got a pickpocket stop old ah let's
look with the steel and then Paul
graphing George short-handed photography
thanks to the coaching staff which team
steel let's go push to coast the score
and
a little bit of breathing room let's go
sausage over kicks it out
[Applause]
George naturally
he cut a sandwich and then sets up small
George how much too kind goodness
yeah that felt pretty good didn't it
[Applause]
thinking about score for trailer mower
[Applause]